hi-yah hi-yah hi-yah hi-yah I know my
dummy quit shoving your red rocket in my
camera space why do I do you have two of
them and why are they in my mind freak
of nature don't you let a baby have
white things going out yeah let me
engage turbo mode turbo mode into my
ball
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Dearman the game were
either you are I are a dear man and
either you or I are shooting either you
or I now if that sounds confusing it's
because I don't know what the hell I'm
talking about oh oh wow
Sunday -5° okay yeah for a quick run
this is as fast as I can run
I'm incredibly out of shape please don't
mind me oh I guess I'm already going
left wait a minute are you trying to
tell me which way to go I'm gonna go
straight ahead because I'm a baller shot
caller ain't nobody gonna tell me what
to do because I have no idea what I'm
doing
oh is that a cemetery oh [ __ ] well
there's an odd place to run I hear
voices in my god covered by snow it
reminded me of my uncle he passed away
in a character not too long ago if there
was something unusual I saw an EDM's leg
sticking out through the tombstones wait
what did I is that what this is oh okay
well that's that's handy dandy I got one
of five I think I see another antler
over there cottage it seemed abandoned
but the door was open oh yeah let's go
into it going inside hello side
it was mostly empty I saw tilted picture
frames hanging on the walls and a dusty
covered by the door hello a letter I
don't know what's going on with you you
leave early in the mornings and come
home late at night the only time I get
to see you is when you're asleep it's
getting hard for me and I'm afraid it's
not gonna work out between us and I'm
sure you know that I'm hoping you'll do
something to make it all good alright
wooden box was locked but I managed to
open who are you talking to I just got
here who peed this message into the snow
I've no idea what you were waiting for
but it couldn't have been me okay
gonna open it somehow somehow I managed
to open it is that an axe can use that
to kill German I remember I took the axe
to kill somebody
okay so I got the accent I got five of
five antlers so I'm assuming I can open
this box I'm ready for you open up open
up open it up it's late in the box I
knew there was something strange
happening in these woods maybe someone
was living here is it the Dearman are
these the deer man's clothes does the
deer men love button-ups
does the Dearman look delight like the
Loch Allegra's really like to look good
on a Saturday evening alright so am I
done have I run enough that doesn't
sound good
what is that okay I don't know what is
what oh hi she's run flag IR you know to
tell me the [ __ ] come back don't look
back I can't why not well she looked
quick I don't know where oh god I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I
don't know where to hide where could I
not look back the second dear man I'm
sorry I looked in your panty drawer
apologize oh god I'm dead
oh Jesus alrighty then whoa Nellie
Nellie lnln
learn on it ah [ __ ] lock it up plug it
up way up there we go
Jesus oh my god I done bad hi how are
you doing hello oh okay
alrighty then bye bye shocking I think
that thing is gone
I should unlock the door and run back on
him should you oh is that a good idea
well let's just take that chance and
okay are we fine okay I think we're fine
oh god damn it huh ah I'm dead I'm dead
I'm going back in no a second what the
[ __ ] I woke with a migraine my vision
blurry I was trying to make sense of
what had happened
am i right the fire burned in the kettle
hissed I saw the thing standing in front
of me well that thing turned out to be a
man holding a deer mask he apologized to
me and explained he took mistook me for
a hunter I assured him that I was not
there to hunt but I questioned why he
would have attacked a hunter he said he
had a reason as he poured a glass of
warm water and handed it to me he asked
me if I wanted to know yes I replied
because I like the woods okay in a small
house near these woods he had a family
whoa a wife and his four year old he
hunted wildlife to bring food back home
earlier hold winter's day he was hunting
deep in the woods they had only enough
food for one more meal it was almost
dark and he was far from home our chairs
had to be quick after hours of searching
he was exhausted and had nearly lost
hope and then he found something he kept
a far distance drew his gun did I oh he
couldn't miss this shot he lined up the
sights and pulled the trigger
bo fell to the ground
he ran towards up to pick it up okay and
right then a baby food came out to live
next to its dying mother he told me it
was the worst feeling of his life he had
destroyed another's family to provide
for his own as tears rolled down his
cheeks he closed his eyes tight and
remembered how many miles he'd taken ah
he opened his eyes and there they were
even my feet all around him oh jeez oh
jeez well I mean you got to do what you
got to do if your family's starving
alone in the woods comprehend he
couldn't believe his eyes it was beauty
what he had done he threw his gun and
ran away
that was the last time he hunted he
finished telling a story as he stood he
reached out to help me up he thanked me
for listening to him I wanted to know
more after hearing a story but it was
time to go we shook hands he held onto
my grip and confided with me I hope you
don't think I'm stupid for doing this he
said of course not I replied deep down
inside I was so inspired by him his
courage protect the deer and his bravery
risking his life it really touched me
and right then we heard a gunshot
follow me honor is near he said donning
his mask he ran to the sound look
hello whoa oh well I don't seem good hey
run towards the bullets okay wait where
are you going you cowards I couldn't see
oh geez
did the deer man get shot I'm pretty
sure this way I discovered that the deer
man got shot
oh my sue he'd been shot yeah somebody
help
I shouted again begging for help but no
one answered it's a big dude yeah well I
mean kind of a bad idea to run around
with the deer head the police found a
piece of paper in the deer man's pocket
it said I take full responsibility of
whatever happens to me I hold no one
responsible I demand the hunters set
free so that on his next time he thinks
twice to take an innocent life from the
wild police did catch the hunter and
drop the charges I could see the hunter
was sorry but well the deer man was gone
we buried the deer man in the same woods
that night I couldn't sleep in the next
day I returned to the woods to see his
grave what is happening thinking
inspiring me showing me how to love the
unspoken wild a baby fawn stayed by his
grave
unfazed by my presence oh I didn't even
see him oh oh geez don't mind me I'm
just gonna pick up these antlers oh god
you're so cute are you so cute oh my
goodness I can't even run so emotionally
devastated by this guy I just met that
was in the woods with a deer mask he
connected to me on an emotional level
what a good guy I mean admittedly why
the deal weren't afraid of me
I walked among the nail they wouldn't
run I felt welcomed in these myths ah
that's when I decided to take the deer
man's mission forward there has to be a
reason to live and I had just found one
well yes it's time to go find me a deer
head oh man I know that's not the lesson
to take out of this but that is quite a
leap I need to say this I totally get
the message of a protecting nature and
connecting who's hit the demon I
remember how he ran towards me and I did
the same no I
oh I started to run Oh faster and faster
I didn't want to stop the deer ran along
with me on my right and on my left after
the right time in my life I felt a true
love with a wild life oh I am
the dealing yeah that's the moral of the
story yeah I'm the dear man you're the
dear man we're all the dear man all
right huh admittedly let me get my
skepticism out of here let me pull out
of my skepticism buddy
hey this seems really like a bad idea to
dawn the moniker of the dear man after
you only met him one dam in the woods
and he seemed pretty crazy considering
that he probably number one he had a
family remember the whole story about
how he had a family
he'd probably let them starve cuz he
didn't want to kill any deer so his
family starred they only had one meal
left now they have no meals left closer
dad and they're buried in those woods
next to the deer man but it's okay cuz
he ran around with a deer mask on to
stop hunters at the expense of his life
and now that inspired you so much that
that's what you're gonna do with your
life and then watch it go but okay I'm
okay I'm stepping back okay but other
than that I think I can I think I can
accept this and I have an idea of what
I'm gonna do about this I I have an idea
of what I'm gonna do
I will be the deer man yeah there's
Dearman in these woods
then we're lurking dark in the forest
there's a deer man we're gonna find him
really I'm doing it look at me I'm on
whoa what she's this never say something
I'm on three be rid of it oh my god oh
my god
I am the gym
[Music]
but their main attack
Oh
would you have to eat it heart what have
you done what have you done what have
you done I have no unter you've killed
this poor unsuspecting creature this
poor beautiful creature here I gotta be
murdered English is that his face yeah
that's his face this is an interface
this isn't a deer this is a man this is
a deer of man you killed man now you
must become the deer hand you bet you
didn't know this was part of it you're
gonna put this on we're gonna shoot you
oh [ __ ] do you feel the deer man inside
you you feel one with the forest yes yes
yes you're so free and in touch with
nature
oh it's glorious you have to do this
you're family okay here's your
motivation your family is starving it's
the dead of winter you have a bad nut
Hauptman throw it down Audrina this is
your child like a child is hungry I'm
hungry he's grown big and strong been
feeding him but you have to feed him
the only deer left in the forest is
right there standing in front of you
okay you have to kill kind of bad deer
to feed your family is with this is it a
swedish deer we can assume it is yes
okay okay give it to Swedish dude it's a
reindeer daddy kill the deer he's sorry
every missed shot is another child gone
the stakes are so high here it is dear
ahh
what are you dear Oh miss precious
creature was it worth killing this deer
we need your family here's the surprise
this is no dear it's a lady under there
it's a human being you're a murderer you
know what you have to do what looks good
night no you're gonna stay right here
and you're gonna put on this costume
we're gonna shoot at you yeah Oh Fred
all right so for you you're alone in the
woods you have no family you ate them to
survive now you have no other options
both of your legs have been chewed off
because you had to take them to survive
yes have a little bit of a handicap but
that's okay you're not gonna let stop
your will to survive is so strong that
you ate all of your babies good they
were good they were very fresh yeah it
was sad though you're very sad so you
have to kill one more thing in order to
survive Oh your starve curing your
nubbly you have no legs
eat eat oh oh oh oh oh oh hold the heart
okay you have no remorse I don't think
you can be the deer man yeah I'm pretty
sure all right
it's gonna carry a carcass away here so
the next one is we have two bows
actually
I'm ready
I am the to me here's the deal
everyone's gonna have a chance to shoot
me got it
so if you hit me transfer your safety
off at her uniform to the next person
and then wail on me with reckless
abandon and then we'll cut up my corpse
you'll all feast we'll have a great time
sound good yes alright you could hit me
even if you try sadly you're gonna take
that sass go get him almost you almost
done go kill him kill him destroy bad
edom thing ya know even
[Applause]
don't eat me please
no no no no